[موسيقى]
ما وراء الافلام مع محمود النجار على
العربيه بودكاست
لو انت كنت عايش في الفتره من اواخر
الستيني
بتفاصيل جريمه ارتكبها بالتفصيل الممل او
الاسود اندرويد
[موسيقى]
عرفت فعلا بزودياكدر مظلم صمت تتهان منه
وشه مش ظاهر وفجاه ضرب نار على اثنين
مراهقين حالا من الغموض والارتباك وعدم
الفهم وهو ده بالضبط ذوق يعني قاتل متسلسل
ما اثرش الرعب قد ما اثار الغموض وما خوفش
المحققين قدم ما استفز رغبتهم في معرفه هو
مين ده هو بيعمل كده ليه الفيلم بيوضح
بدايه التحقيق في قضيه زودياك على خطين
مفصلين التحقيق الخاص بالشرطه واللي عمل
دور المحقق براءه
يستخدموا ادواتهم كويس قوي فمثلا
بشكل احترافي لما فنشر كان بيحب يوضح ان
القصه بتتحكم اكثر من وجهه نظ كان بيستخدم
الزوايا الواسعه ولما كان بيحب يوصل
الاحساس بالواقعيه خصوصا في مشاهد قتل
الضحايا كان بيستخدم القصه على وجه الضحيه
مع وضوح تام لصوت الطعنه او ضرب النار اما
استخدامه للالوان ففنشر بيستخدم الالوان
علشان يحكي حكايه علشان يقول بيها حاجه
وده كان واضح جدا في فيلم زودياك جرائم
قتل صورت في اضاءه مظلمه وبالليل بس مشهد
قتل بحيره باريسيا غير ده تماما كان اللون
الاصفر المشرق للارض مع لون البحيره
الازرق بيدي احساس بيوم هادئ ومباد بس مع
ظهور زوجك في هدوم السوداء المشاهد هيحس
بانزعاج في عينيك لون خارج تماما عن فلات
الالوان المعروضه قدامه فيحس بتوتر الضحيه
مع دخول زودياك عليهم اما بالكلام عن
الازرق والاصفر
لهم سيطره كامله على مشاهد الفيلم وده
اللحظه
بيتكون من خطوط زرقاء وصفره وده اللي بيدل
على سرعه الداخلي في انه مش عايز يجاري
هوس جريسمت المتزايد بالقضيه وصرعه
الداخلي ان هو اساسا كان معوز بالقضيه قبل
كده ثانيا في مكتب الجريده هتلاقي لون
الاصفر منتشر في اللبس من العواميد
الاجندات واللي بيبتدي يتلاشى تدريجيا مع
تقدم الفيلم بمرور الوقت مع ارتفاع زودياك
وانقطاع رسائله اللون الاصفر كان بيعبر عن
سيطره زودياك على التفكير على الاخبار على
الكلام وبما انه يوحي بالتعب والحذر
والسيمه احيانا فهو كان اللون الامثل
للتعبير عن سوريا مين بقى زوديا في الفيلم
انت بتسافر في رحله البحث عن هويه زوديا
بتتعرض لمشتبه فيهم كثير جدا بتمسك دليل
على شخص علشان يدلك على شخص ثاني رحله
البحث دي بتمشي فيها مع ثلاث شخصيات
الرئيسيه بتوعنا
افيريزماس في خلال الرحله دي هتقابل ارثر
في الفيلم ريك مارشال اللي كان كل الدلال
بتشير له وكان ناقص بس جار الاستماع
عليه بفوجيني اللي كان عنده الدليل على
اذان تراك مارشال وطلع في الاخر يدين فاجن
مي شراك طب مين فيهم زودياك هتعرف في
الاخر كل جريمه قتل بيكون ليها الدوافع
وجرائم القتل المتسلسلين بيكون وراءها مرض
نفسي في اغلب الحلقات بس زوجك على حد قول
الشخصي في واحده من رسائله كان بيقتل بغرض
التسليه متاثر جدا في فيلم ذا موستنج بس
هو فعلا كان بيقتل عشان يتسلى ولا علشان
يتشاف زوجك كان اول شروطه ان رسائله يتم
عرضها على التليفزيون هو اللي هيقتل ثاني
وكان بيدعي في اكثر من رساله انه وراء كذا
جريمه قتل حصلت بس بيكتشفه في التحقيقات
ان مش هو مرتكب الكلام ده من الاساس زوجك
طلب بشكل واضح انه يتكلم على الهواء
المحامي المشهور ليه على الهواء وهو كان
عارف عنوان بيته وبعث له رساله
ازاي حد يكون بالعموض تخفي ده وفي نفس
الوقت يعمل كل تصرفات دي بشكل عالمي اللي
لو هو عنده حب للظهور وده تحليل للشخصيات
شوف الفيلم بيقول لي انت وجهه نظرك ايه
الحقيقه الفيلم بالنسبه لي في ثلاث مشاهد
همستر سي اول مشهد لما توسكي محققين
الشرطه راح يقابله ليه لاول مره وهنا
بيبان قدر الاحباط في عينيهم كل الدلال
واضحه حتى ارتباكوا في انه يخفي الساعه
اللي كان عليه علامه زوديا اللي اقتبس
منها شعره واسمه وباقي الادله واعترفه
بوجود سكاكين في عربيته عليها دم لكن ما
قدروش يثبته اي حاجه لانه كلها ادله ظرفيه
ثاني مشهد لما جريس ماس راح لبيت بوب
واكتشف ان الدليل اللي كان بيدور عليه
علشان طلع دليل
نظرته وقتها انه ممكن يكون حاليا واقف
قدام زوجتك نفسه الفيلم ده بقدر من التوتر
والفضول المطلوب بالضبط
اما بقى اخر مشهد فهو الايقونه بالنسبه لي
اللحظه الجريسماس راح فيها ليه بعد ما جمع
باقي الادله وعرف انه كان يعرف اول ضحيه
ليه بشكل شخصي واتاكد ان هو زودياك بس ما
قدرش يثبت برده لانه كل الادله الظرفيه
وبالرغم من ان المشهد كان صامت تماما بس
عين جريزمس قالت كل حاجه قالت الجمله اللي
بتقوم عليها رحلته ورحله بحث كامله
22 سنه من ضرب النار عليه واللي بعده
خروجه من المستشفى اختفى تماما ومش عارفين
يوصلوا له يعرض عليه صور لمجموعه
ولكن هل تم القبض عليه
[موسيقى]
وتفضل النهايه مفتوحه الخيالك عزيز
المستمر هل هو فعلا زودياك ولا معجون
الضحيه اختلط عليها الامر بعد مرور السنين
دي كلها
اجابتك واستناني في الحلقات اللي جايه
فيلم جديد من بوتجاز تمارا الافلام المقدم
من العربيه
[موسيقى]